[Music]
this is deepmind the podcast
i'm hannah fry a mathematics professor
and your trusty guide to the rapidly
evolving field of artificial
intelligence
so far in this series i've spoken to
people who are using ai to advance
scientific discovery you have techniques
that can tackle some of the hardest
problems that have eluded the brightest
minds attempting to solve intelligence
do people still roll their eyes every
year it becomes lease
and using ai for real-world problems
like weather forecasting the dream here
is to warn people before really extreme
flooding events
each of these tasks is enormous in its
own right
but there's a fundamental challenge
running in tandem
ai needs to benefit everyone not just
those who build it
[Music]
deepmind's mission statement is solving
intelligence to advance science and
benefit humanity
we really need to take
that mission seriously and to ask
questions about what does it mean to say
advanced science and humanity
for shakir mohammed a senior research
scientist the only way to live up to
that is to create ai that works for all
of society
the last set of people who said they
were going to advance science and
humanity created colonialism they
created a structure of division in the
world we cannot be complacent about what
it means to put forward a mission like
that into the world
this is episode 8 fair for all
let's start at the beginning if the goal
is to build ai that's fair for everyone
what does it mean to be fair
you might imagine this is a question
with a simple answer fairness surely is
just about ensuring that one group of
people doesn't end up disadvantaged over
another
unfortunately once you try to put that
into practice it quickly becomes clear
that sometimes competing definitions of
fairness can contradict one another
let's take gender as an example
until a few years ago if you searched
for the word ceo on google images you'd
just get images of all white men ceos
this is sasha brown from deepmind's
ethics team she probably like most
people thinks that an image search
showing no credible female ceos at all
is not exactly an example of a nice fair
algorithm
people then think that a ceo has to be
white and male but also because of the
way that the algorithm works whatever
comes up on the top page is more likely
to be clicked on and therefore is more
likely to stay near the top page so
you're kind of reinforcing this
stereotype
now there are a number of ways that a
researcher could alter this search
algorithm to make it fairer
for example they could tweak the first
page of results to achieve a more even
gender balance 50 female 50 male say
over 50 of people in the uk are female
but seven percent of ceos in the uk are
female so should you have seven percent
it's not a simple question as to like
how fair is fair enough so if i google
ceo now i'm looking up now
oh okay things have changed then because
let's look i would say it's
predominantly white male but on the
front row the third image haha there is
a white woman and a black man actually
there's pretty good representation
across the board there is i don't know
about your research but on mine there's
hot ceo romantic novels
yeah i've got that
steamy
in this example then some slightly dodgy
romantic fiction aside the search
algorithm is not designed to accurately
represent company leaders as they exist
but to convey how they might look if
company leaders were more representative
of society as a whole
this is an active choice
sometimes you don't want your algorithms
to be a mirror you want them to reflect
a version of the world you'd like to
live in rather than the one that you do
because a very real danger of unfair
algorithms is that they can serve to
perpetuate stereotypes or biases about
certain groups in society locking us
into a cycle that's difficult to break
if you cast your mind back to earlier in
the series you'll remember lisa ann
hendricks a researcher on the language
team while studying for her phd lisa ann
was co-lead author on a rather
brilliantly titled paper women also
snowboard the study looked at algorithms
which automatically generate a caption
for a given image this is a car this is
a dog that kind of thing
lisa and her colleagues realized that
when these image classifiers were shown
images of people snowboarding
they were much more likely to label the
person as male
even if the person in the image was in
fact female or their gender was unclear
i'm just sort of imagining you in grad
school right you'll sit in front of your
computer with loads of pictures of
female snowboarders and it's just
labeling them i mean was it every single
time man snowboarding man on a snowboard
jumping
not always but frequently
the opposite was true for images of
people in kitchens who were more likely
to be identified as female
it turned out that the image classifier
was focusing not on the person in the
image but on their surroundings applying
a pattern it had picked up from the data
that men were more likely to appear in
images with snowboards
when you trained models on this data it
magnified and amplified this bias and so
whereas at train time maybe you had a
skew of 70 30 men women snowboarding now
at test time you have 90 10.
what lisa ann is referring to is a
phenomenon known as bias amplification
somewhere in the algorithm for reasons
though hard to pin down
any initial unfairnesses get exacerbated
and those initial biases tend to arise
during what's known as train time
when a huge online library of images is
manually labeled and categorized by
humans
humans go on to a crowdsourcing website
and write sentences that describe the
images so you had some images where the
person was very obscured you know really
wasn't clear how anybody would make a
judgment on something like gender and
they would just say man because they
themselves had a stereotype of who
snowboards which is another place where
bias can arise which is that a lot of
times we think that humans are going to
give us ground truth and when you're
talking about anything sensitive it's
not always clear what the right way to
label something is
once they recognize the image
classifiers were biased lisa ann and her
colleagues shifted the algorithm to
focus on the subject of the photograph
rather than their surroundings
but the truth is there are no easy
answers here
de-biasing detoxifying or weeding out
stereotypes from ai systems
is much more than just a technical
challenge that can be solved with a
corrective algorithm
and you won't be surprised to hear that
it's not only gender bias that crops up
in ai systems but racial bias too
there are countless examples of image
classifiers which completely fail to
recognize people from particular racial
backgrounds
in 2020 there was an outcry over an ai
tool which takes pixelated images and
converts them into high resolution ones
it had been disproportionately trained
on images of white faces a bias it duly
demonstrated when it transformed a
pixelated image of former u.s president
barack obama
into a picture of a white man
another example that has come up is an
ai facial recognition technology
incorrectly identified 28 members of the
us congress
as people who had been arrested for
crime this is auburn aka global
education lead
the first matches we are
disproportionately
people of color imagine if such a tool
was deployed at scale it means that
black people like me will be walking on
the street and maybe suddenly stopped by
the police who have identified me
through a tool that tells him or her
that i'm a criminal
these kinds of biases are a real concern
particularly when they appear in
predictive algorithms where historical
data is analyzed and used to predict
what will happen in the future
a recent study found that an algorithm
used on millions of patients in america
to identify which of them were eligible
for an advanced healthcare program was
biased against african american patients
the algorithm was told how much money
had previously been spent on a patient's
healthcare expenses and use that to
predict their future needs
that idea might make sense on the
surface but the algorithm was found to
be disproportionately rejecting black
patients from the advanced healthcare
programme
the data didn't have to have any
information about race in order to have
racist outcomes
sasha brown from the ethics team again
so the algorithm based its decisions and
it assigns risk scores to patients on
the basis of the total health care costs
they'd accrued in the year before and so
they assumed that the higher the total
healthcare costs the higher the need of
the individual
and they even checked and they found
that the average black person in the
data set had the same average healthcare
cost as the white person in the data set
so they were like okay this is fair
but then on closer inspection they saw
that the average black person in the
data set had also been sicker than the
average white person in the data set and
so actually it was unfair and it was
discriminating against black people
historic disparities in access to
healthcare meant that less money had
been spent on black patients with
similar needs to white patients the
algorithm falsely concluded that black
patients must be healthier than white
patients and refuse them advanced care
it's an interesting example because
people tend to think okay well we've
removed the race bit of the data set and
anything that we think is a proxy for
that and so it's not going to cause harm
but actually if you do systematic
reviews of algorithms you see that in
the real world it is actually having
impact where historically
underprivileged groups are getting less
help as a result of this
[Music]
for some these examples of how ai can
discriminate against particular groups
are not aberrations but part of a
broader historical trend of how the
negative impacts of new technologies are
disproportionately felt by society's
most marginalized groups
we know that periods of history have
caused harms to specific communities
right and if we look at modern
technology through that lens we see very
similar patterns and certain uses of ai
william isaac is a senior research
scientist on deepmind's ethics team
if you listen to series 1 of this
podcast you might remember william's
work on the use of racially biased
algorithms in the u.s criminal justice
system
in may last year william was one of the
authors of an influential paper on d
colonial ai
can you give me an example from history
where science and technology has been
used to exploit marginalized communities
the most salient one for me is the u.s
public health studies that were done
from the 1930s all the way to the 1970s
on african-american sharecroppers
in 1932 scientists began a study of
syphilis in tuskegee alabama
at the time there was no known treatment
for the disease
600 african-american men were recruited
for the study in return for free trips
to a physician and hot food
of those 399 had latent syphilis but
none were told of their diagnosis or
what the study was for
only that they had bad blood
[Music]
over the following four decades the
scientists wanted to study how the
untreated disease would evolve
about halfway through the experiment
penicillin became the standard treatment
for syphilis
it was almost totally effective against
the disease but the scientists did not
offer it to their patients
even as many of the men went blind or
developed severe health problems the
scientists continued their experiment
by the time the story broke in 1972
28 of the men had died from syphilis
while around 100 others had passed away
from related complications
this is one of the black marks in
history in the scientific community
because it not only represented
the kind of power imbalance that you
know science can have in communities but
also it eroded trust in the
african-american community
for william a decolonial lens reveals
clear parallels between the treatment of
black communities by today's biased
healthcare algorithms
and the medical researchers of 1970s
america
being conscious of these historical
parallels is one thing
but d colonial ai urges those involved
in designing ai not to repeat the
mistakes of the previous technological
revolutions
the decolonization of ai is also a
project of hope
shakia mohammed was a co-author of the d
colonial ai paper
it is a project to say that we can come
from a world that was built on slavery
and genocide on exclusion and
discrimination but actually we can try
to design a better world that's my
number one hope that everyone they don't
have a reaction to this word
decolonizing but they actually see that
it is asking us to think of a different
future than the one we've inherited
for william and shakir building ai that
benefits all of society goes beyond
fairness in the narrow sense of
achieving equal algorithmic outcomes for
all groups
it involves thinking hard about where
why and in which circumstances ai
systems are deployed
take the example of a facial recognition
system for entry into an apartment
complex where the majority of residents
are black
because facial recognition systems are
traditionally less accurate for people
of color
residents suspected that developers were
trying to attract more white higher
income residents into the block
they successfully prevented the facial
recognition system from being installed
and so this the intentional acts of how
we use these systems is also equally as
important as whether or not the system
meets this goal of having equal
performance across groups so if you just
look at the system whether it's fair or
not you would miss the entire point of
where the negative externalities of a
system lie
how
long do we have to wait
until people stop making the exact same
mistake
over and over again
i hope not too long even if the first
step is like we don't release systems
out into the world that actually impact
people until we address the kind of
underlying challenge around data that
would be a good first step right i know
we're not going to solve all the
problems with embedded buys and data i
don't think that's an attainable goal
but we can control which ones are
released out into the world in high
stakes settings like whether or not
you're going to be able to stay with
your kids or whether or not you're going
to have housing or whether or not you're
going to go to jail
but as the example of the housing
project demonstrates the issues around
consent and data privacy are becoming
all the more important as ai is
increasingly deployed in the real world
and in some cases the question of what
an ai claims to know about you
and who it shares that information with
can have serious consequences
take for example a notorious paper from
stanford university in 2017
which announced an algorithm that could
accurately predict whether someone was
gay or straight from a photograph of
their face
the algorithm in question had been
trained on thousands of pictures of
faces from a dating website together
with their sexual preferences and
boasted 81 accuracy in identifying gay
men and 74 for gay women
there was just one problem
trying to determine someone's sexuality
from their facial features is what's
commonly known as junk science
it's hard to even know where to begin
with that paper this is kevin mckee a
senior research scientist we met him in
episode three where he told us about his
algorithm for altruism
last year kevin co-authored a paper
about the impact of ai on queer
communities
you could potentially be falling into
the trap of thinking that there's some
sort of causal link between someone's
appearance and the way that they
identify and again it's leading you down
a very dangerous path
what might seem like a silly gimmick to
some people
could have grave consequences if it were
deployed in some parts of the world
here's william isaac again
there are governments who would likely
use a system even one that was
completely inaccurate and just junk
because there's a belief that machine
learning systems confer a sense of
authority about information and
prediction and this is why these are
particularly pernicious systems
and although these so-called gaydars are
fake pseudoscience
there are other ways that an ai tool
could genuinely threaten the privacy of
lgbtq plus people
every time you like a page or you
interact with someone else online you
generate digital traces the challenge is
when you have an algorithm that can kind
of sweep over all of those different
traces and start to say things about me
that i never intended to be public so if
i did not want other people to know that
i'm queer but then you know someone
designs an algorithm that's able to
predict that that's a huge challenge to
privacy
the
harms against queer communities i think
take many different forms today shakira
mohammed is also a co-author on the
fairness for queer communities paper
an everyday experience is being in an
airport and you are in those scanners
one really significant harm to our trans
community is that those scanners require
the operators to click beforehand male
or female
what shakira is referring to here are
the full body scanners that use x-rays
to look underneath a person's clothes to
detect any illicit items
an airport security officer might assume
that someone is male click the
corresponding button at which point the
scanner alerts the security guard that
this person has something concealed in
their chest area
but say this person is undergoing a
gender transition
they've been singled out and humiliated
by a machine that expects a man's chest
to look a certain way
that is a form of dispossession and that
kind of benign automation is something
that really affects people on their
day-to-day living experience
and as much as ai can threaten the
privacy of queer people there are ways
in which a carefully designed ai can
have a positive impact too
for instance in march 2021 a charity
which supports young lgbtq plus people
in america known as the trevor project
unveiled a chatbot named riley
riley simulates a conversation from a
young genderqueer person in crisis
the idea is that conversing with riley
can help a volunteer understand how best
to respond
honing their skills for the real
conversations they'll have
when they matter the most
so far in this episode we've considered
how researchers think about ideas of
fairness and decolonial ai to ensure
that their systems don't discriminate
against particular groups
we've also looked at some of the issues
that can arise from the deployment of ai
systems in the real world
but an important part of ensuring that
the benefits of ai spread to everyone
is making sure that more diverse groups
of people are present in the labs where
ai is built
how you actually get to really safe and
robust technologies is you have
different lived experiences looking at
the same technology from different
lenses and are empowered to actually
make sure that you live up to the kind
of building of like having technology
that is safe especially when you're
working with transformative technologies
that will impact billions of people
and there are no prizes for guessing
which groups of people are currently
underrepresented in the field of ai
one way to think of it is
how many
people are graduating from ai phd
programs
that's album aka again in north america
for example
it's estimated that the female graduates
of ai phd programs have accounted for
less than 18 percent
of all phd graduates on average in the
last couple of years as a father of
three beautiful girls that gives me a
lot of concern
the other group i swear that is
predominantly underrepresented is black
people like me
and other minority ethnic groups here in
the uk in 2019 black people made up only
three percent of the tech workforce
listening to this you might be wondering
about a question the auburn gets asked a
lot about the ai industry as a whole
why can't we just diversify that's what
every organization should have done from
the word go
one of the biggest challenges is
recognizing how systemic these issues
are
so is it that there aren't enough people
from the underrepresented groups that
album talks about who are trained in ai
to a high level there's always an
argument in the field around oh the
pipeline doesn't exist so you can
actually find people to hire and all
that i don't think that's true let's get
as many people that are already out
there let's change our recruitment
processes and all these things we can do
to tap into the untapped talents that
already exist out there but also while
acknowledging that there is actually
more work that needs to be done to
invest in the longer term pipeline
people from underrepresented groups
often don't make it as far as pursuing
phds in ai
in fact they drop out much earlier
here in the uk a government study found
that female students are much less
likely than their male counterparts to
study science technology engineering or
maths at a level other studies have
found that black students are more
likely than other ethnic groups to drop
out of these subjects at all stages of
their educational career
and while you don't always need a phd in
ai to work in the field
a background in one or more of these
subjects is a useful asset for an ai
researcher
it's this principle of making people
aware of the possibilities of a career
in ai that guides deepmind's own
education program
we've recently launched a program called
the deepmind academic fellowship to
actually support
early careers such as
to pursue postdoctoral studies in the
field of ai and then below that at the
post graduate level we've created the
scholarship program
which provides a very general
scholarship to students to pursue
masters and phd degrees in universities
aubum ekeke has seen first hand how the
promises of technology can inspire
people's careers i grew up in a very
rural and poor village in nigeria and at
the time i was in secondary school there
was a boy about my age who went to the
city on holidays
and one of the days we were playing
and he said to me he saw
this car in the city
and somebody tried to touch the car and
the car started shouting all of a sudden
and he said to me that you could
actually go to university and study the
thing that made the cartoon shout
and then he said so many other things
this thing can also help you to cure the
disease
later i realized that what this boy was
talking about was just a remote control
right so which has nothing to do with
computer science but what that did for
me was it actually helped me to be very
interested in studying computer science
at the time to solve problems that
existed in my community
as an example of the sorts of benefits
that ai could bring aubum told me about
a mobile app developed in 2018
by penn state university in
collaboration with google
the app uses ai to help farmers diagnose
diseased cassava crops
cassava provides food for over half a
million africans daily my parents used
to be peasant farmers so i used to go to
farm a lot the challenge we had with
cassava
is that they are mostly affected by
viral diseases which makes them
eventually inedible
a group of researchers developed a
solution using machine learning
that could help farmers better identify
and manage the diseases that affect
these cassava leaves by just waving
their mobile app on the cassava leaf
that's exciting for someone like me
right seeing that this kind of solution
could be deployed across africa
technology capable of making a profound
difference to countless communities
already exists
but there is a conspicuous lack of a
major ai presence in many countries
around the world
this is a fact that hasn't been lost on
shakir muhammad
in 2016 while attending a prestigious ai
conference he and some fellow south
african ai researchers started asking
themselves a question
why are there no other south africans at
this conference why are there no
africans to begin with at this
conference and actually maybe part of
the question is we don't need to see
them at these kind of conferences there
may be other new spaces we could create
that doesn't need to necessarily always
comply with the mold
it was this germ of an idea that led to
shakir and his fellow researchers
creating the deep learning in dhaba a
non-profit organization whose stated
mission is to strengthen the machine
learning and ai community across the
continent of africa
in dhaba which is a zulu word for a
gathering or meeting has been running
for around five years and led to some
impressive projects
take for instance the masakane nlp
project the name means we build together
in zulu and began when african
researchers recognized that none of the
current language models those gigantic
tools powering smart speakers and
chatbots could recognize african
languages
[Music]
one of the challenges is that there
aren't
language data sets for many african
languages or 4 000 of them the diversity
of language means that there are very
small communities of speakers of those
languages
local linguists are collaborating with
ai researchers to gather oral and
written data sets in several african
languages including swahili
in kenya for example
if ai is going to enter this world of
finance what they call fintech it
matters that that fintech development
product for mobile payments is in
swahili we have serious problems today
across so many of our countries
particularly in southern africa related
to the hiv pandemic one solution as the
need for advice for hiv but other areas
of maternal health care for example have
come on board is to create these kind of
mobile chat healthcare advisory it
matters that that advice comes in the
languages that people speak because the
ability to understand the true context
matters it's a different form of
representation which is why the kind of
narrow idea of diversity of the
workforce is always incomplete
as we've heard throughout this episode
the challenges of bringing the benefits
of ai to all of society are significant
individual algorithms need to be fair
and ai needs to create local benefits
for everyone not just those who live in
countries with a strong research
presence
addressing this problem will require a
more diverse workforce a more democratic
spread of ai expertise across the world
and the inclusion of a broader set of
perspectives in building products and
algorithms
we have a great deal of power because we
are the ones who decide what the data
set is if we decided to create a
different kind of data set a different
kind of prediction gets made
we can humble ourselves as researchers
to leave the bubble that we are in and
go to different kinds of communities to
come together as new kinds of grassroots
organizations and they can create a
powerful pressure on the world around us
initiatives that deepmind researchers
are working on from indarber to the
scholarship program are a start
but no one company can tackle this alone
we need to partner with other
organizations we need to work with
universities the government has a role
to play we need to work with a
cross-section of stakeholders to
actually
collaboratively
make progress
ethics has to be the input into what
tech we build and not an afterthought
and it needs to be all researchers
responsibility to think about the social
impact of their tech
it's not going to happen by default it's
going to take loads and loads of hard
work i'm excited to see
what does technology look like when you
have everyone involved in the process
what new ideas do you develop because we
won't have the same kind of clustering
effect of the same four or five ideas or
uses for technology they will look
different right and that's a good thing
and i think ultimate is the future that
i believe will get with time
we'll be looking towards what the future
holds in the next and final episode when
i sit down for a rare interview with
deepmind's co-founder and ceo demis
osabis the outcome i've always dreamed
of is
agi has helped us solve a lot of the big
challenges facing society today
you've been listening to deepmind the
podcast i'm hannah fry and the serious
producer is dan hardoon at whistledown
productions we'll be back soon